let's go back to the phones let's talk
to marcus in seattle
marcus how we doing good man doing great
helping yourself
good hey first and foremost um how's
how's the fires going are you and your
family safe y'all doing okay
yeah we're doing fine uh we got some
rain last night yeah it looks like it
cleared up the smoke a little bit
oh that's fantastic what a blessing well
marcus how can i help good man
so um i have a question how do i break
the family cycle of behavior
how do i convince my daughters to get
counseling when they do not want to talk
to a counselor my daughters are
10 and 12. a little back story
i'm active active duty of 14 years i've
been going through a divorce process for
almost a year and a half and i was
awarded full custody of my girls
in march during the divorce process my
ex was ordered to get a psychic out
it came back with an intermittent
explosive disorder and paranoid
personality
there are other behavior issues on my
exercise of the family
that i'm concerned with my ex has a set
of twins with someone else
and she is called my youngest the
youngest daughter a traitor
screamed at my oldest daughter because
she didn't get the response she was
expecting
uh and she claimed that my daughters are
not mine and
i believe that they are my girls she's
throwing
baby bottles at me full of
water spit in my face assaulted me i
caught her on video and turned it into
the police
and she's facing the domestic violence
charges
she has claimed mental disorder in her
defense
and now we're waiting on her to get
evaluated for the trial uh she went to
ncis and claimed that i sexually
assaulted her
nine months after our last sexual
encounter
uh also she went to a navy organization
and claimed that
the girls were harming themselves but
has no evidence to support the claim
she has a history of control issues
where she's not in control of the
situation she becomes out of control
all right hey marcus marcus yes
you've told me a lot about her tell me a
lot about you
as you've been talking it sounds like
you're a broken exhausted
ex-husband and you're a broken exhausted
dad
am i right yeah
do you love those two girls dearly
and then and then with uh govid
and having to deal with home school all
the time
yeah thankfully my uh
my command has worked with me so i can
be here during the day when
when they need me most but you know this
is the
hardest yeah
so marcus i want to tell you a couple of
things number one just
dad to dad i love you and i am grateful
for you and i'm proud of you
okay because what you're going through
is a nightmare
nothing gets in a dead soul like
somebody messing with his girls
and i know that that's their mom i know
that that's your wife
and normally i'm pretty protective of
ex-parents but this sounds like a
situation that is
about their safety their physical safety
their psychological safety their
spiritual safety
and so i want to reiterate you're doing
the right things
i know that it's a
defcon 2 pain when somebody reports
something to your administrative
structures and ncis and those crews have
to go through the rigamaroo
that's such a beating and they want all
your texts and emails i know that just
sucks man
and so just the exhaustion of it i want
to hear you
and say this sucks this sucks and i'm
sorry
um a couple of things
that i want to put out there for you and
then
direct you to a few places number one
your daughters are 12 and 10
they don't get a choice yeah
they have to um everything that they
know
to about relationships they learn from
their mother
and from their dad and you know this
with just forgetting the diagnostics
here
they did not pick that up from mom and
they are going to have to have they're
going to have a
a significant learning curve and a
relearning curve
this counseling i'm going to recommend
y'all do it together for the foreseeable
future
because they're going to have to learn
with the help of a neutral
third party and with you involved how to
have a real relationship
and my guess is right now broadly they
don't know how to do that
they've got a dad who is going to war
for them literally and figuratively
as a 10 and 12 year old they don't
understand that yet right they don't get
they will
circle back and realize oh my gosh my
dad
what an incredible man they're just 12
and 10 they don't get that right
and so what you want to do with family
counseling right now is to help them
turn those alarms down
to turn those off and or at least quiet
them it's going to be hard as long as
mom
is continuing to be a part of their
their lives
and i'm going to tell you something
marcus i don't normally tell folks
you told me you got full custody is that
right yes
so you're gonna have to be pretty
protective of them and
their interactions with their mom
because mom's not safe
mom's not right now she's limited down
to text messaging
because of her conduct and i would i
would
be relentless i wouldn't give my 10 and
12 year old a phone i've got a 10 year
old and he doesn't know how to turn on a
phone to save his life
i'm i'm kind of a lunatic about that
kind of stuff but
i would be relentless about checking
their phones checking their
communication
because as she as your daughters get to
be 14 15 and 16
and they're going to be desperate for a
womanly presence in their life
mom's gonna transform to this cool hip
friend
right is gonna turn into this person
that dad's not right
and so i would be just relentless
just relentless and um be over attuned
to
things like physical touch make sure
you're hugging your daughters you're
holding their hands you're looking them
in the eye
that you come home turn all your
electronics off and make them the center
of the universe for a while
and i know that's hard it's not
convenient that's
mind-numbing and frustrating but man
you're in it and i wish
i could tell you otherwise more than
anybody in the world
as a as a soldier you know there's just
moments when man we're just getting
shelled and this is just
this is it and you're in that season
with these girls
and i can hear in your heart that you
love them and i can also hear that
you're
exhausted so here's my question for you
do you have a place where you can go be
well
where you can get a break where you can
put your oxygen mask on
um not really because uh
in the mornings i'm here with the girls
and then and the
uh you know i go to work in the
afternoons
so all right so marcus uh marcus
you are worth being well brother yep
and you are worth getting a good night's
sleep
you were worth eating okay you're worth
working out a few times a week
you're worth falling in love with again
and if you don't take care of yourself
you know this
it's you're going to end up face down in
the mud
yep okay and i don't know what that
looks like for you
i'm i'm talking from a i'm with you is
what i'm saying
when people in my life are hurting my
self-care goes out the window and we
just have to remember that old thing
from the airplane pilots that
if we lose cabin pressure we got to put
our mask on first or everyone in the
in our road dies all right well i am
lucky i do have someone in my life
okay so that uh that i have found so
that
good she has been a lifeline good um
so when it when it comes to talking um
to your daughters
you're gonna have to walk a a balance
and i'm gonna recommend you don't bad
mouth mom
you don't talk bad about her being crazy
or she's this that
i would let your daughters know that
mommy's sick mommy's sick
and she's not doing well and daddy
loves them more than life
itself daddy loves them
more than they will ever understand and
the older they get
the more fun stuff y'all do the more
connected y'all do
maybe y'all keep a letter writing
journal where it's a spiral notebook you
have with each
each daughter and her job is to write
you a note every day
and when they go to bed you'll read it
and respond to it or you'll wake up
early in the morning don't read those at
night time because sometimes it'll be
pretty dark
but wake up in the morning and respond
to them and let them know that you love
them but it's going to give them
something tangible they can hold on to
and make sure you are taking care of
yourself but going back to your original
question
12 year olds 10 year olds they don't get
a vote on whether they want to go to
counseling or not
especially in this situation they will
go
you will all go this is something that
you are going to be in for the long haul
and i'm not a fan of going to counseling
forever this is something you're going
to have to invest in because your
daughters are going to have to relearn
and i say relearn when we think about
knowledge right we think about our
frontal lobes i'm not talking about that
right now i'm talking about our
amygdalas they're going to have to learn
their bodies are going to have to learn
how to
whoo how to relax how to breathe
and how to be in a relationship with
other people and they're probably going
to struggle with this for a while
thank god they've got a dad who loves
them more than life itself
thank you for your service to our
country
equally as important if not more thank
you for being a dad who gives a crap
marcus there's too many parents who
don't care
who write their kids off god bless you
man for being in the fight with for your
daughters
um ah what a gift what a saint brother
thank you so much for your call
and we'll be thinking i'm proud of you i
want you to give me a call back marcus i
want you to give this four or five
months i want you to give me a call back
let me know how things are going let me
know how counseling is going let me know
how your
intentional connection with your
daughters
eye contact daily journals together
prayer time together working out
together whatever that looks like i want
you to know i want you to come out call
me back and let me know how things are
going
i'll be thinking about you